Speaker 1: It's great to welcome to the
program today, Steven Donziger, who's a
human rights attorney who helped indigenous
groups in Ecuador win a historic $10 billion
pollution judgment against Chevron.
If you want to help what he's doing,
you can go to free donziger dot com. It's really
great having you on. I appreciate your time.
Speaker 6: Well, thanks for
having me, David. I appreciate it.
Speaker 1: So to start with what first brought
your attention to the effects of oil drilling
in Ecuador and and how did you
first get involved in all of this?
Speaker 6: Yeah, it's a great question.
I mean, I was a year out of law school
back in the early 90s. I was one of my classmates
was from Ecuador. And he told me about this
and I was part of a team in the early 90s that
went down to investigate what turned out to be
the worst oil disaster on the planet. Or so
we thought. We called it the Amazon Chernobyl.
Essentially, what we discovered is that Texaco,
an American company now, Chevron had deliberately
dumped billions of gallons of cancer, causing
oil waste onto indigenous ancestral lands in the
Amazon, creating a wave of cancers and other
health and economic problems for the people.
We filed a lawsuit as a result of that first trip,
and 28 years later, here I am. Still, our team is
still fighting to hold Chevron accountable. We won
the lawsuit, by the way. They just have not paid
yet. And that's where the battle is at this point.
Speaker 1: There are so many different aspects
of this to talk about, including the eventual
charges against you as you talk about the fact
that the judgment has not been paid. Just
to pick something. And we'll kind of go
through these different things as this was
going on and you were working on this. The
documentary film Crude was being produced, and
one might argue that the production of the film
opened the door to allege fraud against you
by what was allegedly left out of the film.
So can you talk to us a little bit
about your involvement in the film
and whether in hindsight it was a mistake?
Speaker 6: Sure. So in 2007, Joe Berlinger,
who's an acclaimed documentary filmmaker, decided
to make a film about, you know, really this epic
battle by indigenous groups against Chevron
and their legal team, of which I was a part.
I thought the film was great. It came out in
2009. It's called crude. You can still get
it on Netflix or on YouTube. But more to the
point is Chevron. When they started to lose
the case in Ecuador based on the evidence,
tried to exploit the film to come after me.
Let me be very, very clear. Chevron is
alleged that I committed some sort of fraud
down in Ecuador. I reject that. It's never been
proven. I've never been charged with a crime.
And the reality is 28 different. Appellate judges,
six appellate courts in Ecuador and Canada have
rejected that that theory. But they tried to claim
that based on the movie and some certain things I
said in the movie, which frankly were impolitic,
you know, just stuff. I was saying that the camera
on, you know, 15 years ago was somehow evidence of
fraud, and it's never been accepted by any court.
And I reject it. And again, you know, the
judgment in Ecuador that I helped win has been
affirmed by multiple appellate courts around the
world. So it's a valid judgment. And, you know,
I just reject that. But it's a good film. People
want to see it because it really does capture a
lot of what was going on in Ecuador at the time.
Speaker 1: It's so true. And to answer the one
piece of that that that I didn't
hear an answer to. In hindsight,
did it create problems for that film to be?
Speaker 6: Well, that's that's the question.
You know, it's funny. That's a very that's an
important question. And I get asked that a fair
amount, like if you could do it over, would you
have made the film? Yeah. I don't know. You know,
when you go through a journey like I've been on,
you sort of operate on the information you have at
the time. You make decisions in the information I
had at the time and my clients, more importantly,
the people of Ecuador, I was working with thought
it would be really good for their campaign to
illuminate via a film, you know, the injustices
that were being inflicted upon them by Chevron.
You know, I it. Nor did they anticipate that how
Chevron would try to exploit it for litigation
purposes had we known that maybe my clients
would have made a different decision. But
you know, at this point, that's water under the
bridge. The fact is that film is out there. Yeah,
it's a good film. And I think overall, my personal
assessment is that it helps the campaign.
Speaker 1: So, OK, I want to be precise in
how I kind of broach this, this next topic. As you
pointed out, there have been allegations made that
the judgment you obtained was obtained
Speaker 4: through
Speaker 1: racketeering extortion. Wire
fraud, witness tampering, money laundering,
etc. You've denied those allegations and you
correctly point out those have not been proven
in court. It's beyond my ability here to examine
every single one of those individually. I've
done a fair share of research about this. I can't
unequivocally say there's no merit to any of it,
but you're completely right that none of it's been
proven in court. Ultimately, your imprisonment in
the United States and the suspension of your
law license was not based on any of that,
but contempt. Is that correct?
Speaker 6: A contempt of court, yes.
Speaker 1: And that is a misdemeanor.
Speaker 6: It was treated that way in my case,
I mean, if I may, I think there's a bigger issue
here that I'd like to point out. Fair, limited
time. We have, you know, because there's obviously
no way in this limited time we can go through all
these allegations, right? You know, the big issue
is it's been proven in a court of law. And Chevron
has admitted that its predecessor company Texaco,
deliberately dumped literally billions of gallons
of toxic waste in the Amazon, which is literally
killing thousands of people as we speak. Yes.
In my view, is their defense strategy. They're
like, Oh, let's distract from that by focusing
on Steve Donziger. OK, so the more we talk about
me and I sort of, you know, when I agree to be on
the show, I obviously knew this. But like the more
we talk about me, the less we talk about the real
problem, which is the poisoning of the Amazon
in a way that is decimating indigenous groups,
even hurtling them toward extinction. That's
the real issue here. So the issue is not me,
it's them. Now, if we want to talk about me and
their allegations against me, I'm happy to do that
and I do that all the time because again, they've
never been proven in a court of law. And you
know, it puts me on the defensive, which I don't
like. Yeah. And to be clear about them. But yeah,
but they're simply, I'm just telling you there's
simply unproven. And in my view, they're not
true. It's just a strategy. It's like a corporate
playbook to distract attention from a human rights
atrocity that Chevron committed by focusing on
the lawyer. And you see this all the time. And
the bigger issue to me in a society where and I
don't think this is a right left political issue,
it's like, what kind of society do we want to
have where you can advocate for people? You know,
lawyers should be able to do their jobs and
advocate without being personally attacked
by the party that they beat in court. And
that's what's happened to me with the help,
unfortunately, of a federal judge here who've I've
accused of being biased and the final thing I'll
point out. The United Nations Working Group on
Arbitrary Detention, which is a very respected
legal body that's been cited by our own State
Department on many of an occasion where they point
out people who've been arbitrarily detained ruled
in September that the United States government
should release me immediately. I'm not free, even
though I'm home, I'm in detention at home right
now. Yes, they should release me immediately
and pay me compensation because my detention
violates multiple provisions of international law
and is clearly retaliation against my advocacy
for indigenous groups in a case that has been,
I think, manipulated by Chevron and the fossil
fuel industry. You know, that's a lot to absorb.
But the the larger issue is my case raised. It
goes way beyond me, and it really raises a lot of
issues about what kind of freedom we want, what
what's the role of lawyers in our society? Can you
do climate justice work without being locked up?
I mean, what's happened to me, I think, is just
wrong, and it's not indicative of the best part
of our country. It's very unusual in the United
States to have a lawyer, a climate justice lawyer
like me locked up, and I just think it's wrong
Speaker 1: with no question. And to be clear,
if I don't mention as a jumping off point for
this conversation that the allegations exist,
I'm not doing my job, but I completely concede
it's beyond the scope of this to adjudicate them.
Speaker 6: Totally cool with how you're asking
the question, and I love your work. Generally,
I'm happy to take the question. I
just wanted to make the larger point
Speaker 1: when it comes to. The ulterior
motives. What is your assertion about the role of
the American court system? Judge Kaplan, et
cetera? And Chevron, formerly known as Texaco?
Speaker 6: Well, I think as a general matter, our
federal judiciary in particular has become very
politicized in the last two or three decades.
In a way it never was before. And I think
I'm sort of paying the price for that personally
right now. You know, there's a whole there's
different groups in the judiciary, and I think
it's pointman of judges has become so political
that you're getting judges now on the bench
that are really carrying out, I think,
political agendas rather than doing what they
should be doing, which is looking at the facts
and ruling on the law in the most neutral way
possible. So you know what Judge Kaplan has
done to engineer my detention without a jury?
I want to emphasize that I never had a jury.
He manipulated the case such that you know that
I wouldn't get a jury. I couldn't defend myself.
You know, in other words, the allegation against
you on the contempt side was that I didn't comply
with this court order that I turned my computer
over to Chevron. And the reason I didn't comply
is I appealed it to protect the privileges held
by my clients in Ecuador. They're privileged
information, their identities. They would have
been hurt. Had this information been released
and been put at risk, their lives would have been
put at risk. So I thought I behaved ethically.
And I'll point out there's never been
a lawyer in the history of our country
who's been charged criminally for doing what
I did. That is challenging a civil discovery
order on appeal. It's never happened before. So
why is it happening to the one guy who actually
won a $10 million judgment against Chevron?
I mean, it makes no sense, and I'll make this
point when Judge Kaplan charge me. He went to the
and why the federal prosecutor here in Manhattan
to ask them to prosecute the case, and
they refused to prosecute me. He then,
rather than letting it sit. He then appointed a
private law firm to prosecute me, Seward Kissel
and he didn't disclose, and we found out seven
months later that this law firm Seward Kissel had
had had. Chevron is a client. It has massive
has numerous clients at high levels of the
fossil fuel industry. So this became, in
my opinion, the nation's first private
criminal prosecution. They immediately detained me
pretrial on a misdemeanor, which is unheard of. I
mean, they lock me up in my home with an ankle
bracelet. And because of covering the trial,
kept getting delayed. That ended up lasting
twenty four months. I'm sorry. Twenty six months,
two years and two months. And on top of that,
the judge, who is also appointed by Judge Kaplan,
Judge Prisca, sentenced me to six months in prison
where I ended up reporting to federal prison for,
you know, defending my clients in the
Amazon. And I just think it was grossly
unfair ended up getting out after 45 days,
but I'm now back home in detention to serve
the rest of my sentence. So all in all, for
this misdemeanor were the maximum sentence
is six months. I am going to end up serving
close to three years by the time it's over.
Speaker 1: And so a couple of other details
on that. At one point, there was an $800000
bail set for a misdemeanor. That's the
highest in U.S. history for a misdemeanor,
if I understand correctly.
Speaker 6: That's our understanding.
So on top of being the first person
charged with this kind of misdemeanor
locked up prior to trial. I was also given the
highest bail ever for a lawyer on a misdemeanor
in U.S. history. And I'll point out that $800000
bail was actually higher than three of the four
police officers involved in the killing of
George Floyd, which I find astounding. I mean,
there's people who commit serious, serious
violent crimes who have lower bills than I got
Speaker 1: when Judge Preska wrote the ruling
against you. There was this question as to
what specific connection there was with
the ruling in Ecuador, and I know you've
generally spoken about political interests,
you know, among the ranks of judges,
et cetera. Is there anything more specific about
Judge Prescot that you think should be understood
or known about the connection to fossil fuels?
Speaker 6: Yes. I mean, let me just say I respect
judges in the rule of law like I'm I'm a lawyer
and I don't mean to disrespect Judge Press,
but there's a couple of problems with her
presiding over my case. One is she's a leader
of the Federalist Society, which to which Chevron
is probably the largest funder. The Federalist
Society is a legal organization. It's a fine
legal organization, but it is very pro corporate
and a lot of corporations fund it. And she is a
very public leader, and she identifies with an
organization that gets funds from Chevron. And I
just think that's a major conflict of interest. I
don't think she should have presided over my case.
And you know, the other thing I'll point out about
Judge Prescot is I don't think she ever should
have been appointed to this case because, you
know, there's rules here in the federal judiciary
and in New York in particular that cases need to
be signed randomly. And Judge Kaplan, I believe,
chose her for a reason. Their close colleagues,
they've been on the bench together for over 25
years. And I think she treated me very unfairly.
I mean, she's the one who made the decision to
lock me up pretrial for over two years. You know,
on a theory that I was a risk of flight like,
I'm really going to I have a wife and a teenage
son. I'm really going to flee. It's absurd. The
country, you know, to avoid a misdemeanor. I mean,
so. So there was all these things happening
where I believe she and Judge Kaplan sort of
colluded to impose a very punitive suffering
on the punishment before I was ever convicted
of a crime. And I will point out that my so-called
conviction, which again, I assert my innocence,
is under appeal. OK right now was imposed
without a jury. I insisted on a jury
so I could have an unbiased fact finder rather
than a person I believe was a biased judge and
judge. Prescot repeatedly denied me. A jury
repeatedly refused to remove the prosecutor,
even though she was from a Chevron law firm,
the private prosecutor. So there were all these
features to the trial that led the United Nations
jurors to conclude there was a what they called
a staggering level of judicial bias. In my case,
Speaker 1: it's it's an incredible and disturbing
story in a number of different ways. We've been
speaking with Stephen Danziger, and you can learn
much more about what's going on at Free Donziger.
Com. I really appreciate your time and you giving
us your insights into what took place.
Speaker 6: Thank you, David. Appreciate
your work as well. Thanks for having me.